[TECHNO MUSIC]
ALEJANDRO MANCHADO:
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Alejandro Manchado
I work on game analytics
and monetization at Google.
Today I would like
to tell you about how
you can supercharge your mobile
game business with AdMob.
AdMob is a huge smart platform
with mind-boggling numbers.
More than 200 billion
app requests every month
from over 650,000 apps in
more than 900 million devices
with full global coverage
in 200 countries.
We have totally relaunched
AdMob since 2013--interstitials,
video, analytics.
The result? oUR Our CPM,
which is the price paid
to developers, has tripled.
AdMob has paid out
more than $1 billion
to developers in
the last two years.
How do we do this at
such a massive scale?
Well, in one single
package we give you
over one million
AdWords advertisers,
programmatic demand from
DoubleClick ad exchange,
mediation of 40 networks, House
Ads, and Google Analytics.
Now the interesting thing
is that AdMob gives you
equal full coverage on
both iOS and Android.
We are also integrating with
the biggest game engines.
We already have
certified plugins
for Unity and Cocos2d-x.
We are building a smart
platform to supercharge
your monetization, use analytics
and understand your audience,
and adapt your monetization
experience in order
to grow both your inner
purchase and ads revenue.
Let's start with analytics.
Last year we merged
Google Analytics and AdMob
in the same interface.
Setting Google
Analytics up is soon
going to be a piece of cake.
You will implement in the Google
Mobile App's SDK, check a box,
and it starts sending
data out to GA.
Now we have recently launched
several analytics features
focused on gaming.
We now support user acquisition
analytics on both Android
and iOS, cohort analysis,
and average revenue producer
and LTV reports.
Audience Builder is
another key feature
that we have rolled out
since GDC last year.
Google Analytics
is a powerful way
to build user lists
based on segmentation.
With Audience Builder, you can
then use these lists in AdMob.
Now this means that
with Audience Builder
you can tailor your
monetization strategy.
For instance, cross-promote
your other games
to spenders, to your
high-volume users,
while you monetize your
casual users with beta apps.
We are also really enthusiastic
about inner-purchase apps,
which we are relaunching.
We can smartly target
these ads suspenders.
In fact, our algorithms,
based on Google data,
can predict which of your users
are likely to become spenders,
even if you don't know them yet
Changing gears here, we are
very excited about a new format
that we are announcing
here today, Native Apps.
We're launching
both content and app
install Native Apps which you
can modify in order for them
to better fit your game
and provide a better user
experience.
A great example.
Atari has partnered with
AdMob to introduce Native Apps
in RollerCoaster
Tycoon 4 Mobile.
You can check out the game
on both Android and iOS
in the next few weeks to
see these Native Apps live.
Last but not least, we
continue to drive paid ads
demand at scale.
In 2014 we grew
programmatic demand,
expanded mediation to
around 40 networks,
and launched automated
live mediation across AdMob
and a dozen other networks.
In 2015 we are going to
scale TrueView Ads, which
are video ads that the user
can skip after five seconds.
And we are introducing direct
sales and programmatic deals
within AdMob.
So to summarize, we are building
a smart monetization platform
with analytics at its core,
enhanced with Google data
and algorithms, so that you can
offer a fully audience-aware
experience to your users.
Finally, remember
also that Google
is a massive user acquisition
platform with more than 1
billion users on it.
On AdWords, for instance,
you can target users
by what apps they have
installed and whether they
have spent any money in them.
So for those of sticking
around after lunch,
do not miss our Analytics
and AdMob Code Lab right here
this afternoon.
We will have several
Google engineers
helping solve all of
your technical questions.
Also, if you're here
later in the week,
do not miss our presentation
this Thursday March 5 at 10 AM.
Google's senior product managers
for Google Analytics and AdMob
will share all of the details
of our 2015 whatnot with you.
And with that, we're done.
You've been an awesome audience.
Thank you very much,
and I wish you happy
monetizing with Google
Analytics and AdMob.